[Música]
en la segunda jornada del juicio
político contra el ex presidente de
donald trump
los fiscales demócratas señalaron al ex
mandatario como el incitador en jefe del
asalto al capitolio del pasado 6 de
enero los demócratas mostraron imágenes
y audios inéditos del ataque
en su primera conversación con su
homólogo chino xi jinping el presidente
yo bailé en crítico entre otros temas
espinosos la represión sobre hong kong y
las acciones autoritarias en la región y
le pidió respetar la soberanía en sus
asuntos internos y resaltó que una
confrontación sería una catástrofe
tenemos información desde beijing
haití vivió nuevamente violentos
enfrentamientos en medio de las
manifestaciones en las que los
ciudadanos acusan al presidente job en
el móvil de mantenerse ilegalmente en el
poder la justicia ordenó la liberación
de un juez de la máxima corte del país
que estaba detenido tras ser acusado de
ayudar de ayudar a planear un golpe de
sal
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torre sánchez
iniciamos este informativo en eeuu en el
segundo día del histórico segundo en
pitch mente contra el ex presidente de
donald trump
los fiscales demócratas lo acusaron
formalmente de incitador en jefe del
ataque contra el capitolio del 6 de
enero los demócratas revelaron nuevas
imágenes y audios del asalto y
reconstruyeron lo ocurrido en una
detallada línea de tiempo que incluso
pudo haber convencido algunos
republicanos veamos más detalles en el
informe
el segundo juicio político de durand
arrancó con fuerza los demócratas
presentaron imágenes inéditas captadas
por cámaras de seguridad del capitolio
el 6 de enero su argumento es que durant
fue el incitador en jefe de una turba
violenta
wayne hubo un aterrador golpe en las
puertas de la cámara
nunca olvidaré ese sonido grite y llamé
de pánico a mi marido ya mis hijos en la
segunda jornada de este proceso los
fiscales demócratas que también
mostraron tweets y extractos de
discursos del ex mandatario se
concentraron en situar el ataque en el
contexto de la cruzada post electoral de
tremp para rechazar la victoria de joe
biden en noviembre
fue un hombre tan desesperado por
mantenerse en el poder que intentó todo
lo que pudo para conservarlo y cuando se
le acabaron las medidas no violentas
recurrió a la turba violenta que está
con su cámara del senado el 6 de enero
parece muy poco probable que los
demócratas puedan lograr la mayoría de
dos tercios en el senado necesaria para
obtener una condena pero los argumentos
parecen estar haciendo mella en la
bancada republicana
la evidencia que se ha presentado hasta
ahora es bastante convincente de ceres
en una serie de vídeos que hemos visto
un nuevo recordatorio de lo que hemos
vivido y por desgracia lo que algunos no
vivieron es muy inquietante después
una encuesta de la agencia reuters
revela que un 47 por ciento de las
personas se aprueba una condena contra
30 otro 40 por ciento la rechaza
previamente en nuestro corresponsal en
washington cristóbal vázquez nos contó
que se espera para hoy en la tercera
jornada del impeachment
pues empieza nuevamente al mediodía hora
de washington y los administradores
demócratas y los representantes a la
cámara que ayer pues presentaron estas
evidencias tendrán nuevamente ocho horas
o solamente hoy podrán seguir
presentando las pruebas se espera que no
se tomen las 8 horas presentarán algunos
vídeos algunos argumentos adicionales y
después será el turno de la defensa de
donald trump
los abogados de donald trump tendrán
también dos días en total 16 horas para
defenderse para exponer su caso y
argumentar porque el trump no debería
ser hallado culpable de este impeachment
después vendrá entonces las preguntas 4
horas de preguntas después de eso
testigos si es que se citan y después la
votación final que según hemos leído y
hemos escuchado de miembros del congreso
podría cerrarse el 15 de febrero
continuamos en estados unidos el
presidente joe biden sostuvo su primera
llamada telefónica con su homólogo chino
xi jingping y en su conversación criticó
los abusos de beijing contra minorías en
la
provincia de xinjiang la represión en
hong kong y las prácticas económicas que
tildó de coercitivas e injustas de hoy
fui informado de un nuevo grupo de
trabajo sobre china del departamento de
defensa que el secretario sostiene está
liderando para analizar nuestra
estrategia y conceptos operativos
tecnología ubicación de la fuerza y
mucho más el grupo de tarea trabajará
rápidamente basándose en expertos
civiles y militares de todo el
departamento para proveer en los
próximos meses las recomendaciones para
el secretario dos tienen temas
prioritarios y puntos de decisión de
manera que podamos graficar un camino
sólido hacia los asuntos relacionados
con china ancha ni late madre el
mandatario chino pidió prudencia sobre
los asuntos internos del país y abogó
por la cooperación entre las potencias
de acuerdo con la prensa oficial china
para beijing es clave que yo byd en
descarte una confrontación entre las
naciones desde la capital china nuestro
corresponsal
adrián foncillas tiene los detalles
la prensa china sostiene hoy que si sin
fin la habría advertido a job aiden de
que debe tratar con mucho tacto temas
como xinjiang hong kong o taiwán porque
todos ellos son asuntos que afectan a la
integridad territorial china y esa es la
tradicional línea roja de beijing sí sin
pin también le habría dicho a job aiden
que la cooperación es la única vía para
solventar conflictos que son no sólo
ayudar a ambos países sino al mundo
entero y que la confrontación sólo
conduce al desastre la prensa china ha
hecho una valoración muy positiva de la
llamada que ambos líderes han mantenido
esta mañana recuerda la vieja relación
que mantienen y se congratula de que
china y eeuu hayan recuperado canales de
comunicación que habían quedado
arrasados durante el mandato de donald
trump también valora que la llamada se
haya producido coincidiendo con el año
nuevo chino lo que es interpretado no
sólo como un gesto de respeto hacia sí
sin pin sino hacia todo el pueblo chino
y por último también se congratula de
que joe biden haya definido las
relaciones bilaterales
de competición pero no necesariamente de
conflicto en mi armar la junta militar
que efectuó el golpe de estado el pasado
primero de febrero realizó nuevas
detenciones contra personas con cargos
de elección popular mientras continúan
las multitudinarias protestas a las que
se unieron diferentes etnias del país a
esto se suma la alerta por una ley de
ciberseguridad que ultiman los militares
y que denunciaron cerca de 160 ongs del
país la normativa permitirá llevar a
cabo apagones de internet prohibir
contenidos y reclamar datos de los
usuarios
la comisión europea rebajó su previsión
de crecimiento del producto interno
bruto durante 2021
previamente se situaba en 42 % y ahora
paso a 38 por ciento sin embargo en la
comisión lo ven como una salida del
túnel de un 2020 sin precedentes nuestra
corresponsal en bruselas esther herrera
nos amplía
buenas noticias para la economía de la
unión europea después de un 2020
catastrófico vuelven las buenas noticias
según las previsiones económicas de la
comisión europea la economía de la zona
euro crecerá un 3 8% en 2021 y un 37 por
ciento en el conjunto de la unión
bruselas cree que en 2022 la unión
europea podrá despedirse de las malas
noticias porque podrá volver a los
niveles de la crisis de la pandemia
mucho anteriores a la crisis de la
pandemia por lo tanto mejorará sus
previsiones económicas gracias a un
crecimiento mayor de lo previsto según
la previsión todos los países europeos
crecerán aunque a ritmos en distintos el
país que liderará este crecimiento será
españa con un crecimiento superior al 55
% en 2021 después de un 2020 en que tuvo
una caída en picado de su economía del
11 por ciento será el país que más
crecerá le sigue
francia con un crecimiento del 55 por
ciento en bruselas cree que se empieza a
ver la luz al final del túnel en la
economía después de una pandemia que ha
afectado gravemente a los países
europeos y se espera que con el refuerzo
de las campañas de vacunación en las
próximas semanas y también sobre todo
los fondos de recuperación que se espera
que puedan llegar a finales del verano
pueda mejorar la economía
sustancialmente por lo que hay motivos
para la esperanza en la economía de la
unión europea en otras noticias aumenta
la atención en haití este miércoles se
registraron fuertes choques entre la
policía y los manifestantes que exigen
la renuncia del presidente yo en el mois
entretanto un tribunal ordenó la puesta
en libertad de un juez de la máxima
corte del país que había sido detenido
con otras 20 personas por supuestamente
ayudar a planear un golpe de estado y el
asesinato de moix veamos el informe
la camioneta de una emisora de radio
envuelta en gas lacrimógeno y otros
periodistas aplicando primeros auxilios
a sus compañeros mientras las protestas
siguen creciendo la policía haitiana ha
sido acusada de una violenta represión
que incluso ha tenido como objetivo a
miembros de la prensa claramente
identificados
las tensiones aumentan en haití con la
población exigiendo la dimisión del
presidente yo en el móvil
el mandatario joven el moisés está
llegando a su fin no volveremos a la
dictadura
los opositores argumentan que su mandato
presidencial terminó el domingo se firme
a sitios desde antes del 7 de febrero la
situación es grave y después de esta
fecha el presidente perdió toda la
legitimidad porque su mandato ha
terminado la situación se ha agravado y
la dictadura empeora
el presidente moix argumenta sin embargo
que juró su mandato de cinco años en
2017 por lo que todavía tiene el poder
hasta febrero de 2022
eeuu ha respaldado esta postura aunque
su embajada emitió un comunicado en el
que dice estar profundamente preocupada
por cualquier acción que pueda dañar las
instituciones democráticas de haití el
domingo funcionarios leales al
presidente afirmaron haber frustrado un
intento de golpe de estado contra él y
arrestaron a 23 personas entre ellas un
juez del tribunal supremo quien obtuvo
este jueves su orden de liberación el
martes moix trató de sacar del cargo a
otros tres jueces que fueron propuestos
como posibles líderes nacionales
interinos por la oposición
la organización human rights watch
asegura que el asesinato de líderes
sociales en colombia significa un
fracaso para el gobierno del país con
más de 400 líderes y lideresas
asesinados a manos de grupos armados
desde 2016 según un informe de la
entidad colombia es uno de los países
más peligrosos para los defensores de
los derechos humanos la ong insta al
gobierno a actuar urgentemente para
detener la matanza de activistas
natalia plazas tiene los detalles
colombia es de lejos el país de américa
latina con más asesinatos de líderes
sociales una conocida verdad que pone
nuevamente de manifiesto la organización
human rights watch en su último informe
los riesgos se dan en los territorios en
las zonas rurales en colombia donde
comunidades indígenas afrocolombianas y
campesinos son extraordinariamente
vulnerables a las amenazas a las
presiones a la extorsión y finalmente
incluso pueden ser asesinados
lamentablemente con impunidad por grupos
irregulares armados por mafias por
guerrillas por grupos disidentes de las
farc el documento señala más de 400
asesinatos de defensores de derechos
humanos desde 2016 pero de acuerdo con
la defensoría del pueblo 710 activistas
han sido asesinados en el país en ese
mismo periodo los asesinatos han
incrementado desde entonces con el
surgimiento de nuevos grupos armados
muchas veces cuando se escuchan de estos
problemas
el gobierno ordena el traslado de tropas
tropas del ejército y esas tropas se
dedican a combatir a los a los bandidos
a los delincuentes que están
precisamente detrás de estos de estos
casos pero no protegen a las comunidades
y la presencia del aparato judicial es
realmente muy precaria la ong pide al
gobierno a aumentar urgentemente la
protección a los líderes y garantizar
que los criminales enfrenten la justicia
subraya que a pesar de la existencia de
leyes para prevenir ataques estás en la
práctica no los protegen días atrás el
gobierno dijo que reforzaría la
presencia militar y judicial pero a
pesar de los constantes llamados de
atención nacionales e internacionales no
ha dado un cronograma detallado de su
plan para garantizar a los activistas el
derecho a la vida
vamos a ecuador porque el candidato
presidencial de centroderecha guillermo
lasso subió al segundo puesto en el
escrutinio de votos tras la jornada
electoral del domingo plazo se
encontraba por debajo de andrés araus
aspirantes respaldado por el ex
presidente rafael correa y del candidato
indígena ya q pérez quien anunció que
pedirá una auditoría sobre los
resultados en seis provincias en las que
supuestamente se habría producido un
fraude
y finalizamos en japón donde fuentes
cercanas al presidente del comité
organizador de los juegos olímpicos'
yoshiro mori anunciaron que presentará
su renuncia tras una polémica por un
comentario sexista durante una junta del
comité olímpico mor y se quejó sobre los
supuestos inconvenientes que representa
la presencia de mujeres en las reuniones
sus comentarios causaron numerosas
condenas tanto en japón como en el
exterior se espera que la dimisión se
haga oficial este viernes en medio de
una junta directiva
y así llegamos al final de esta emisión
recuerden que pueden ampliar toda la
información en nuestra web france24
puntocom en breve continuamos con más
noticias
[Música]